et bien bonjour je suis assis sur son
canapé aux côtés de mes trois gros
collègues et dit que l'adil kesa
production et je regarde la john campisi
présent je suis très heureux que vous
soyez là j'ai préparé ce concept depuis
un bon moment
nous allons nous affronter pendant les
trois prochains jours deux équipes joker
mois casar et freddy compte c'est ça
dans chaque équipe se trouve un
potentiel chanteur est un mec qui sait
manier un logiciel de production
musicale pendant trois jours on va
chacun est dans notre studio et on va
devoir faire un hit de l'été
nom acide faucon s'il était avéré fort
de l'été c'est quoi c'est un second coup
là en tant qu' un peu dans son extérieur
pour des ce que vous voulez vous avez le
choix pouvait faire le genre musical que
vous voulez et vous avez trois jours
pour ça à l'issue de ces 3 jours vous
aurez donc fait le but vous aurez donc
trouver les paroles vous aurez donc posé
sur le beat bref vous aurez fini que
votre son et on l'enverra au mix nous
pareil de notre côté pendant tout ce
temps on n'a aucune idée ce que vous
allez faire vous avez aucune idée de ce
qu'on va faire on se retrouvera une fois
que le sort a été mixé donc le son sera
dans son état final près est diffusée et
on découvrira chacun le hit de l'été de
l'autre équipe ok pour l'instant ça me
va c'est bien d'expliquer aussi mais
c'est quand même une battle ya quand
même un gagnant dans l'histoire donc
nous allons envoyer nos sont à remettre
de la chanson française
un artiste qui a vendu énormément
d'albums ont énormément de stream j'ai
pour cela la même chose je suis mal
l'actif cet artiste nous enverraient un
petit vidéo lui qui découvre nos sons et
qui donne son avis et qui élit selon lui
le gagnant
ok ça ne s'arrête pas là parce qu'on
veut aussi la vie des gens donc ce qu'on
va faire après ça c'est qu'on va chacun
clip et notre son et ça sortira 48
heures après cette vidéo là que vous
êtes en train de regarder donc les deux
clips sont en moyenne sur ma chaîne et
c'est simple on le clip qui aura le plus
de j'aime qui gagnera la bataille donc
vous découvrirez en même temps que nous
le clip de freddy et casas et vous
découvrirez en tant que le clip de jack
à et moi est-ce que tout est clair et
lucide il me semble les amis c'est parti
pour qui fera le meilleur hit de l'été
on vraiment le nom d'une émission télé
patrick ouf
et pourtant des sur youtube et ça va
être mouffe je pense aussi les amis
c'est parti c'est pas tout de suite
après cette explication de lucas on se
retrouve là en bas vous savez pas mais
on est en bas du bâtiment dans le studio
qui est également le studio je sais pas
si on peut le dire mais deux mc fly et
carlito ok tu l'as dit le summer hits
comme on le fait que ce soit hyper à
joyeux dans les accords dans les
instruments je pense ça je voulais être
triste pour l'été c'est bien tout le
monde fait ça dans ton monde reste
enfermé chez soi et pleure mecque pour
moi à hit de l'été c'est latino en ce
moment ci connaît c'est pas ton avis
c'est toi le boss mec m'a submergé ma
vie pour un bon hit de l'été si vous
êtes prêts à charbonné comme geagea ou
comme diageo
règle numéro 1 laisser la place à la
voix il faut que dans notre instrus on
est des petites notes un petit peu caché
un petit peu et tout comme ça pour que
la voile puisse ressortir de ouf et
qu'on est peu d'éléments pour que
justement là vous apprennent tout
l'ampleur on peut chanter posée mais
fauqué de l'auto tune je pense mais de
l'été yade l'autodrome sur l'avant c'est
évident et mec j'ai mes lunettes je me
sens plus mes gars avec qui je suis
habitué à cette liste on parle de lui il
est décédé le ponant et continuons de
nickel moins de cinq minutes par
d'autres artistes
dick rivers est mort aujourd'hui la 73
ans bompard sur quoi bah je sais pas le
soleil quoi ce à dire que tu écoutes un
truc tu bronze des gros ne serait pas
mal pour ça respire le monoï tu vois
quand koundjia cap d'agde pour ce conte
moins de budget mme way ce qu'au moins
de budget et bree crise et au sud de
paris qui dit pas mal dans le jargon je
pense qu'on va employer des plug ins et
des petits sainte et ses traits au dm
dans le style décidément il ya que des
mots qu'on connaît peu
à vichy ok avec un petit instrument
genre sur le refrain un petit truc un
peu de limites tu vois un truc est
réglementée en fait le hit de l'été
c'est ça c'est un truc qui reste en tête
mais que l'été ouais en septembre à
l'appel
ok c'est que pour l'été t'as pas des
preuves des trucs à faire écouter mon
stock comme sa tête on peut mais j'en ai
quelques jeunes du quelques prods soit
lequel j'ai avancé un peu dans des airs
latino comme ça va je me dis totalement
cet enfant si c'est de la merde tu me
dis c'est de la merde
azé
[Musique]
on garde pour après mais déjà le petit
synthé très bien gentil de dire moi mais
si tu mets derrière il est là voilà
derrière
tiens ça s'est tellement bien c'est
vraiment bien là il ya un potentiel fou
ce que je veux faire écouter la
maintenance est plus classique vraiment
latino reggaeton classique pur plus
récents tu me dis totalement ce que tu
en penses ces dernières
ok donc je pense prend la 1ère prod que
tu as fait adam servir de base et on va
modifier la structure etc pour atteindre
d'autres choses bah ouais du couple oc
santé blog un peu haute et en
contretemps mec j'ai envie de te dire
que tu m'apprends ce qu'est le plug je
te laisse mes goûts je pense qu'on va
trouver face à un pack c'est pas ça veut
pas ça non plus ce que c'est ça non je
veux qu'on commence par la mélo le petit
lit de mélo j'aimerais juste comme un
délire je pense moi je trouve ça pas mal
donc là on va trouver l'instrument qu'on
utilise déjà moi j'aime bien utiliser
des petits simple composante à ça tu
vois tu vas prendre ça tu le sens qu'il
était très à l'est comme si un train
passait vraiment non mettant à plat tu
vois et tu vas juste un petit truc et on
peut la garder soit longue comme ça donc
faire juste trop note ah c'est pas mal
lalala lalala rajoute derrière le voir
ce que ça donne mais que j'aime bien
pasqua envers les caméras bonjour
dauphin soin d'eux ok j'avoue tout est
un peu mon mec de studio gens branchés
mais je suis utile comme ouais ouais bah
je pense que déjà premier truc que tu
peux faire c'est genre appuyé sur rec tu
vois c'est ça c'est des gens hyper i
think i font ça on va dans une
responsabilité d'ouvrir le 6 mars et a
pu page en scène le son et ligue de
hockey balle a dit on à orly se plaque
[Musique]
le plug normalement c'est bon je pense
que c'est un rite déjà franchement bien
on arrête là bas tu peux pas arrêter
comme ça ouais c'est vrai il faut quand
même aller plus loin tu veux dire je
suis trop optimistes non c'était surtout
très pressé ok donc on a trois options
on a celle là convient de 15 ans sans
rien et on a été deux autres prod que tu
avais d'avant ça se termine
[Musique]
l'autre bien plus reggaeton cette
dernière tombe c'est de la merde et du
coup on a ça sur la fin bon c'est
vraiment il ya trois pistes
ouais pardon je sais pas c'est quoi la
vraie les deux premières étaient pas mal
en ce fut vraiment d'accord et s est
forgé qui sont d'accord je me disais
qu'on voit la première il plus reggaeton
je me tâte et faut que ce soit dans
l'ambiance
permets moi de vous élever
et là c'est bien là
c'est très bien aller bien elle est bien
allée bien au port un sandwich on
revient on checke les pistes etc
on voit ce qu'on peut arranger et on
bosse dessus jusqu'à la fin d'aprèm
tabac rentrée vous venez pour nous
espionner
on va à la boulangerie acheter sandwich
ne voulais pas je trouve sa voie
tu nous fais acteurs non bancaires tout
le reste c'est vraiment encore plus
fourni un excellent temps de troll hamel
tandem groupe
c'est le bruit qui a quand tu lances un
jeu et tape sur start je me suis assis
sur 2009 où les descendre et/ou passer
quelque chose
j'ai pu sur un pool maillot moi je suis
plus sûr de la méfiance aux moyens on
voit bien pour tuer les sandwichs je
peux prendre tous avec moi c'est pas
possible il en train de le faire le mix
de la voie de la masterisation une photo
de nature internationale à portland ça
c'est un petit challenge pour le
guetteur théoriquement quand est sur une
lancée et que tu tiens en mon truc tu
t'arrêtes pas pour la bande en sandwich
est ce que finalement ils vont chercher
à manger où chercher genre de lundi
[Musique]
très important quand on n'a pas de badge
aller franck mois comme dans le métro -
amicale tout comme le bas du canton n'a
pas accès à l'ascenseur on se colle
comme ça mais non ça marche maintenant
ça c'est pas utile oui je connais son
moment où on va arriver demain on va
tout entendre à il faudra peut-être les
prévenir non non c'était le mur sert du
coup oui cette idée fasse incroyable je
vous apportons poubelles à bakool jeter
votre prendre parce que vous vous pensez
que vous allez faire un carton deschamps
a dit jeter votre propre mais si vous en
avez 3 les gars il ya de la place
mais on a fait trop en plus ça fait
trois fois ses pas et là quel poids a
été réussi est ce que vous voulez un
mini indices annoncent pour aider on
veut en fait max et de sandwiches parce
qu'on est repassé dans le bureau d'un
ton téléphone ont leurs mandants vous
montre la vidéo on est passé vite fait
on est revenu dans le studio ils sont
versés
parce qu'il n'y a que deux cadreurs donc
l'objet de films avec le téléphone mais
y'a plus personne au bon média
tg est allé casser je peux voir et
reprenez votre poubelle de merde là on a
bien qu'un micro vett ce témoin que
c'est faux vous êtes témoin de cet
honneur
bon retour de la pause déjeuner désolé
c'est le carton dont on vient de vie en
danger sur importe ils sont essayé d
avoir en flagrant délit
c'est bon ce qui s'est passé on a changé
un petit peu la mélodie parce qu'elle
était assez complexe et leur répartition
très très simple qui donne quelque chose
comme ça c'est de faire écouter pour les
gens ils voient bien tout ce que tu as
fait le piste par piste exact donc déjà
pour aït de l'été il faut la mélodie
principale la catch qui est ça
[Musique]
tu ajoutes tout ce qu'est la partie ça
donne ça totalement là-bas seul
c'est pas la bonne note qui tellement
plus qui vient en plus dans la
messagerie qui est très très bien en
plus mais ça s'appelle un bloc la pêche
app locker pêche bien sûr au mexique où
le to qui dure déjà être sur des
mélodies qu'on a choisi est sûr qu'il ya
toute la matière dont on a besoin et
ensuite surtout faire la structure du
morceau à savoir quand est-ce qu'on
ajoute la base quand est ce qu on la
retire quand est ce qu'on a dit ça j'ai
exactement ca le gros du taf quand même
je trouve là on a un gâteau là c'est un
gâteau au yaourt pour l'instant et bah
kribi n'est pas très bien qu il ait pas
très beau en plus il faut juste ben faut
le refaire en fait ouais non moi je
pensais voilà en fait c'est là où je
pense qu'il faut l'ageecj en une petite
voix sur sako je vois quand on s'en fait
pas non on valide ça valide pas c'est
pour ça qu'il faut vraiment que je
laisserais sinon tu vas le faire genre
[Musique]
tu sais quoi moi je dis on enregistre
bavoirs tu veux pas seulement clarico je
t'ai tuer des êtres qu'addictif ouais on
trouve une note way home et sur l'étang
regarde remet sa c4
on ne sait pas avoir eu si c'est trop
cool et du coup ça a créé un rebond est
ce que tu aurais pas une petite voix qui
fait ok go sinon le phénomène mec mais
grave on fait même
mais bien sûr j'avais vu leur gestion a
fait comme ça je suis désolé mais c'est
vraiment pour le son qu'on fait ça quand
on refait
je pense qu'il faut que je traite là bas
liddell un lidl leader
saleh presse comme little mais c'est en
moins cher en fait je voulais dire un
petit peu lire en anglais vraiment sûr
avec des mecs décarie en studio je leur
dis lol tu as conduit donc là je dis ça
fait marrer les français et parce qu'on
n'est pas on en retard on revient dans
trois minutes le temps que je trais
cette voie et bien bienvenue dans la
suite de cette création musicale
je crois
les questions au compteur c'est juste
jaloux on a utilisé de tout cas qu'à
légendes et des petits oh oui il est
beau je vois du pont sur turf et plages
de garde
donc est-ce qu'on va réussir à rendre ça
intéressant je vais aller vers la
tendance je vais proposer une petite faq
salut qu'à telle quelle année je voulais
savoir écoute le suivait en 1996 pardon
le temps je bosse je suis en train de
bosser soissons en fait donc je peux il
parle mais les a fait face mais la
question la tan a pas marre de copier
puis payet genou non qu'avec nous il
fait son travail c'est je pense que
traiter comme ça c'est très bien c'est
bien là que ça arrive moi qui ai les les
hits hâte c'est le terme qui là et je
sais même pas ce que c'est là on a un
truc juste vas-y de test mais que sa
fille accrochées au mur
c'est ouf sa fille de pro b derrière
geyrhalter une guitare
parce c'est un homme un vrai truc en
[Musique]
plus c'est pas trop le genre de basket
dans l'essonne org est un mail
donc petite originalité on se laisse
aller quoi tu perds mais les petits
trucs et je trouve ça chauffe ça cool
attention ces prêts pour aller en
espagne j'allais report la mecque
mais je suis là bas la corrida quoi vous
tuez des taureaux cgd au mauvais endroit
en espagne en france revient ce soir et
il vient tout droit d'angleterre ce soir
il nous fait l'immense honneur de poser
son empreinte ce soir c'est une star
mondialement connue
il n'en est pas à son coup d'essai merci
d'accueillir souvenir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toi
[Musique]
c'est ça qu'on veut
gaubert
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que là on passerait pas à l'étape
presque final j'en veux dire avant
l'écriture d'accord donc le yaourt exact
topline yaourts ou alors le fait de dire
n'importe quoi pour mélodie je pense sur
un morceau et donc du coup de trouver
les flots et ça va être hyper
intéressant c'est pas la partie la plus
crédible et la plus exactement elle est
bien celle là ne dis pas qu'on n'avance
pas parce que l'on rangera line hockey
mais je sens qu'on va l'oublier ça allez
c'est à ton tour tu es prêt à
enregistrer ce yaourt lisbonne top line
3 2 1
[Musique]
demain
j'ai plus de sous non non non non non ok
bah sinon bah sinon une boucle à l'ena
teaser si vous l'écoutez base est tac
là vous allez bien rigoler je pense
parfait l'a pas pourquoi tu vas toi tu
n'es way juste envie de voir ça donne
envie
[Musique]
j'ai plus de sous et ben moi je pense
qu'elle peut très bien passer demain
enfin d'autres sont ses deux mains
surtout qu'on va se concentrer sur un
script vocal parole flow topline vocal
la finition la prod soyons sûrs de quel
instrument auquel à quel moment voilà ça
a pris une dimension sérieuse en une
seconde où on était là et bien venir
exemple romance mais là on est là ouais
je pense que demain on finit des voix là
on va trouver les petits one on écoute
fin de première journée moi je trouve ça
cool on a bien avancé on à la prod on
n'a pas gagné et ça c'est bien je trouve
qu'elle est plutôt plutôt efficace
qu'est-ce qu'on fait du coup c'est ce
que montrent une dernière fois où ou
team allez voir bah oui s'il est si on
va voir l'évolution aller j'ai des
enfants à récupérer ces fous et elles
sont allées pas de spoil pollet j'allais
dire est ce qu'au niveau avec les
oreilles bouchées
voilà on fait un comme ça vient on
parlait de toquer à la porte
ouais bon la même tête qui sort
bienvenue dans cette convention
j'ai vu un peu votre travail tout à
l'heure oui je voudrais savoir un petit
peu comment ça comment ça a pu évoluer
finalement dans votre recherche
artistique voilà alors je tiens juste à
dire à nos adversaires qui sont ici que
nous avons déjà fini vous allez faire
quoi pendant les deux jours qui restent
on va écrire et enregistrer et j'allais
dire on va peut-être écouté notre zoom
qui est déjà finie tant les deux jours
qui restent c'est hyper insolent et je
veux juste leur faire écouter la piste
isolé des cas attention il ya une
concordance un peu entre moulins à huy
faites gaffe et un beau métronome de la
town wazza balourd c'est juste ça la
preuve qu'on a fait là aussi sentir
comme 500 ouais les gars ça ça c'est
gagner à l'est pas plus loin tu viens de
le faire en live oui oui la même non
mais oui c'est pour ça en vrai talent ok
les gars challenge vous devez refaire
exactement cette roquette jordan je
commence
[Applaudissements]
ses proches voire très bas les bras à
l'ozone gaza l'a noté l'a noté lors
pourquoi pourquoi elle était d'ailleurs
à tempérer c'est ok ça c'est vraiment
honteux sud à bâle
les proches situées arrive on
l'applaudît vous dégagez c'est bien beau
de vagues sur un matelas dirait ce bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mec
on a une prod tente et comptant déjà
plus très content donc on a un préau
frencq hachiro faut qu'on trouve la top
line leur frein principal
moi je pense que dans le débat l'édition
c'est trop bien c'est moi je suis le
gars qui sue en moquez un aigu et toi
que tu es à grosse voix espagnols c est
comme ça dans le refrain on peut se
répondent
demain on trouve toutes les taux plein
dit on écrira les paroles demain soir je
pense et après nous allons poser suite
on est bien quoi franchement on va voir
les autres
vouloir faire seulement c'est la fin du
jour un jeu vous êtes content de ça fait
neuf mois
il ya quand même un truc que j'aimerais
c'est que vous ne fassiez coûté quatre
notes parce que vous avez écouté 4 alors
j'aurais tant aimé
malheureusement j'ai tout débrancher
demain sa crainte du coup pour le délai
avec not so 6,6 donnant le droit si note
soit je suis éclaté sa mère pas choisi
le 8
ce oui c'est une passe en aile et c'est
long c'est quand même un truc avant est
un génie c'est quand même con voilà la
halle et à des voitures mais esther suis
je pas cette journée vous plaît monsieur
vous êtes vous plaît à bientôt au revoir
au monde il est ici fort latence et là
ils nous ont fait écouter leur premier
vrai gros qu'on vous fait pas un jour
elle est venue
victoire de m
on est de retour
hall 1 jour 2 on a bien envie tu as bien
d en vivre il va plutôt bien les romands
un présentateur très moyen aujourd'hui
on va se pencher principalement sur la
topline c'est à dire le yaourt de la
musique
freddy a eu de nombreuses idées pendant
la nuit 2 c'est pas top mais ça tourne
partout pour vous est ce qu'on aura un
bon choix dans l'assistance pas à quelqu
un arrêt à un mouchoir pour sa crotte de
nez
bah c'est un bon début de journée de
bienvenue dans cette deuxième journée
la technique aujourd'hui ça va être de
faire plein de topline dans l'église au
moment de voir lesquels ont regardé
lesquels on garde pas écoute je te
proposera deux bandes enregistrées dans
ok bachelot est ce qu'on commencerait
par tata plagiat c'est toi je fais le
mec tu fais l'ingestion
allez montez mac c'est pas très agréable
les aigus
[Musique]
c'était pas ouf mais qui souffre mais la
belle avait lavé les banques
bon ben abbés la bd boum boum ben bella
bella bella bel et bon ben voilà ça
passait les biens communs c'est l'équipe
qui avec nous c'est important d'avoir
vos avis pourquoi on est con on est dans
les cordes et dans les codes ça ça veut
dire je kiffe pas pour cemex
je sais même plus ce que j'ai fait mais
je les ai mis dans mon ordi avec mais
peu de moyens qu'est ce que tu as
vraiment enregistré comme cela qu'il ya
un micro sur le board
est-ce que tu as vraiment fait un micro
je vous entends pas vraiment la 1re fin
après on va en faire trois quêtes on va
voir j'en enregistrais player ça va être
un chien toi mais sait on connaît on
connaît la note vocale
allez salut en annuler il faut savoir
que c'est un exercice qui est hyper
dignité se livrer en temps plein c'est
compliqué vu que j'ai fait un truc et je
me souviens même plus que j'ai fait
attention attention
moi je trouve ça pas s'affronter vrai
c'est sûr vous en avez autant vous fait
d'être sûr de mon neveu papa non non non
non non non non non
on attend cela revient en fait ouais
c'est exactement ça gêne pas là je sens
et est laissé emporter un peu comme ça
c'est lourd tu peux te montre mon micro
faut-il faire attention ce rating
je veux une musique suspense pour ce
micro 4 3 2 1 les rennais d'aller dans
le dédale aide
bah oui si la vraie au mieux au bout de
ma tête je blogue
messieurs du son
ah ok
à elle est mortelle t bone est très
bonne et je pense qu'on peut y aller du
coup sur la table je veux ta meilleure
voix d'homer timbre dit que tu veux
inventer la variante électrique hésite
peinture comme ça on a détruit qu'on
allait probablement d'autres idées aucun
doute choqué non non non non non non non
non non non non non moi je n'entends pas
ça va être horrible
[Musique]
j'avoue moi si je t'ai dit bye bye bye
bye bye bye
il faut le faire lors du bye bye bye bye
je sens bien seul à avoir
[Musique]
est ce que je peux te refaire la fin de
mon prêt refrain c'est pour ça tombe
bien que le tien ok c'est parti je te
dit bye-bye si tu fais les buy
ça marche ça marche moi je pense que ma
partie alarie photos et le top 10 tu
fais ta raison je te dit bye-bye si tu
fais les noms du coup falloir fermer en
haut je te dit bye-bye si tu fais les
buy
ok c'est pas écouté je te dit bye-bye si
tu fais les bras en v on le garde aussi
là dessus mais on va être en harmonie
peut-être faut tester laquelle élargir
leurs montures dans mon cul pendant ce
temps chez kaeser
du rock
oui ça lui manque un peu le pack terme
des pme l'impression qu'on fasse pas ce
verre ça va les gars écoutez on avance
plutôt pas mal
vous êtes content ça certainement là ça
a pesé des voix en attirer d'autres
freins non c'est quoi il ya des infos là
sur le sur l'écran c'est dingue non
techer décès quand tu viens nous on
voulait proposer des cafés nous voulons
des cafés ouais on tenait à ce que vient
il n'y a plus qu'à écrire pour vous faut
15 avions fait ce geste est question
ouais quoi tomber c'est dire ce que tu
écris et la soul connaît
[Musique]
pourquoi le chien est morte hier vous
êtes venu vous proposer ensemble
est ce que vous vous souhaitez quelque
chose une boisson gazeuse pour moi ce
serait cool ok c'est les plus chers à la
machine allez on amène ça tient au
courant l'efficacité de notre problème
et savent pas que leurs revendications
ok mais j'ai une explication pour que
l'ambiance est déjà le cas avec le
dictaphone où beaucoup auraient tous
mais que j'ai stressé comme un mec qui
avait volé un truc tu vois ok je veux
dire puis les dégâts vas-y paie les
dégâts
c'est un moment vraiment il ya jordan
qui comme ça chantait regarde le meuble
même du doigt zirn le téléphone il
appartient peut-être un cadreur
crédibilise la carotte et on va
récupérer les infos il faut faire pareil
je passe devant avec ça tu passe deux
jours à tuer leur fille et tu peux
peut-être faire des dégâts
pour le tout dernier belga
t'es ok je peux dire un petit truc sur
l'écran de et quoi comme ça il regarde
l'écran je le mets attention on arrive
mais aucun des carmes des mots aux
canneberges en panne de temps à sept
têtes alors attends je me protège la
marsa tu veux monter parce que c'est
cognac
d
des fois tu mec je suis plein de bonnes
intentions on vient troubler la moitié
d'un coupé deux heures jordan ne doivent
pas chercher
est ce que tu peux me souviens qu'après
la vie on peut faire ça versailles
mais pour le moment ce chien voilà ça
fait qu'apple c'est moi qui te mords ils
sont les mauvaises intentions à savoir
si un accident et que tu es encore tu le
fais tu fuis belle à dagar elle sait que
si jamais tu peux être un truc bien
moins importante je suis des vertus
si tu fais des bêtises tu es là deux
gars je pense qu'il faut qu'on les
laisse bosser mais qui je pense aussi
travaillé bien légal on viendra me voir
pour conclure la journée de n'oubliez
pas ce qu'on vous foncez c'était il ya
trois mois mais je regarde pas sans
tache et le gabon c'est bien là tout est
ce que quelque part un volet quelque
chose si tu n'as pas activé
l'enregistrer sait-on encore ça tourne
depuis quatorze minutes
il n'y a peut-être la prendre et le
flingue au refrain je te propose de
descendre parce qu'on ne peut être pas
et qu'on sera ici et c'est parti à 37
ans il faut vraiment que je paie une
vidéo montre qu'on écoute pas tooway
alors enregistrer mes gars a quand même
bien eu écoute ce que vous avez fait
[Musique]
mais je vais vite appuyer sur pause
après paie les dégâts je fais délégué
général fait des dégâts
je vais couper je vais leur envoyer tout
le reste inquiet ok là je fais modifié à
trop bien
bîmes bon les gars vous avez bien vu on
écoute pas on se parle pas on a dépeint
je vois sur une peau de saint sava
d'adieu à la pelleteuse un appel allô
allô
ouais ça va ça va être quoi 10 - est-ce
que vous avez regardé la conversation
voile simple non
tu veux qu'on la regarde regardez là on
arrive elles ont bien audio adage le
mais c'est toi qui chantes comme vous
ont laissé un mic les batailles sens
intrigue d'espionnage mag et bata allez
c'est parti on revient au cinquième
étage et son passé deux fois dont ils
ont dû laisser un téléphone avec le rec
allumettes et chambard et sont revenus
pour nous alimenter les boissons et ont
repris c'est ça c'est ça c'est ça
et ben mec c'est quoi ils ont 15 ans
elle voulait jouer à sa cause avec
freddy vous est terminée je vais sur
caméra bande de mer des foules de
confiance comme ça est-ce qu'ils vont
lui ont valu les deux les deux longs lui
paraître on peut voir la notice là
[Musique]
vous voyez ça ça va aller dans leur
merde dans l'environnement
on pourra les voir
là je m'en sers pour une heure juste me
touche pas
[Musique]
regardez regardez
salut excusez moi en fait ils prenaient
trois quarts les choses j'ai
l'impression bon genre de 300
alors écoutez moi bien vous que vous
allez c'est inacceptable non mais ça et
la vengeance elle va t elle va vous
faire mal aux ce qui est du projet c'est
lui c'est toi freddy que sa luge et 7
passes et freddy tu aurais fait ça on
s'est fait un câlin non mais je veux
plus a dit je regrette
chacun a ses conséquences président
cassez vous sachez que je vienne pas
combien de votre studio dans moins d'une
minute soyez très vigilants mon chien et
même plus là vous êtes un fait un truc
assez bon maintenant bon les gars ça
tout ça puisque c'est toi aussi tu sais
ce que c'est vous êtes dans le colisée
si on y arrive c'est amusant ça j'adore
tes conseils faciles à corrompre une
équipe technique quoi bon les amis du
moulin foot hand studio on va fêter le
leur pour ça c'est très simple on va
leur faire diversion la semaine à cause
de la pièce ok freddy et kesa l'on
regarde et se doteront pas qu'en fait
c'est une personne l'équipe technique
qui va positionner la caméra allez les
gars à la barre sont là ou pas c'est
qu'on est des plus beaux textes
est ce que les gars si vous payez
souvenez vous on n'a pas eu les six
notes
je suis très gentil vous allez avoir la
foule en cours parce que la foule un
troll inconnu lic pas tout ok ok ok je
suis confiant ce que ce monsieur
[Musique]
parce que nous on n'a pas le retrouve
après on reviendra vous voir pour la fin
est pas mais ce qui me fait pas de coup
ce n'est pas rien n'est gagné rien mais
je viens confiance mais juste vous
accompagne en fait ils lèvent les mains
et on sort les a toutes une méga travail
et bien donné tout et on se retrouve
après ok les gars mais oh les mecs
alors qu'est ce qu'on y donne je te dis
bah quoi ça cache un truc ça n'en ont
chanté knocked up like gens d ok allez
bye l'épicerie est un succès je t'ai vu
tu es magnifique mais il faut prier pour
que sa cape l'orifice je pense qu'il a
caché un truc moi franchement je les ai
pas lâché du regard je pense qu'ils
auraient recours et nous ont rien fait
ça a marché mais c'est déjà tout un
micro que cette table un truc c'est
qu'on va découper la moquette on n'a
rien en dessous des gars faisait près je
clique sur la vidéo en direct annonce te
plait ça marche c'est vrai ça marche ça
sent bon pour monter sur un échec s'il
n'avait pas de nouvelles de cette
opération c'est que c'est un échec
jusqu'au
j'espère que ça va marcher
bougez pas ton baptême voyant le mur
s'il te plaît on c'est bon pour son
ultra travail je savais qu'il y avait un
truc les batailles dans la vidéo plus de
mecs c'est énorme comme on n'a pas vu ça
on est bête parce qu'on est parti là bas
ils sont trop chaud c'est qu'on a rien
vu c'est ouf
ils ont perdu plus malin que nous c'est
qu'ils sont amenés à l'opposé se sont
mis comme sale oppose et attendit c'est
ok ok je sais je sais quelle est la
vraie vérité ces gorilles avoir un
cadreur ou en ingé-son qu'ils ont mis
dans le truc c'est ça avec c'est sûr je
pense l ingestion
on va voir sa tête les ingestions ils
savent pas trop mon tir j'ai rencontré
jean on n'a rien vu a bien fait et
charges appui dans ma poche
messieurs quand on craque ya toujours ce
moment deux comme ça et je ne serai que
vous avez un écran bien défini est ce
que c'est la conclusion de la vidéo en
fin de journée c'est quoi ce brut
quelqu'un a reçu un message c'est
choquant selon une notification de
attendant a atteint ces sommets les gars
voulaient vu quand c'est ça ça vous
l'avez vous êtes rentré dans notre pièce
un moment et j'ai posé une question à
quelqu'un j'ai dis à ton âge et son qui
est là tu mets tout le visage de cet
homme si fier je vais arriver je fais m
es tu cap reçoit avec ta perche là
puisque tu n'es pas du tout dans notre
direction et il était comme ça vous êtes
bourg tout et hop line sont sur votre
source
y'a plus qu'à écrire ce soir demain
matin est apposée sur le son directement
en vidéo ça dure bon bah les gars et
merci pour cette deuxième journée
neither à demain pour la troisième
journée de qui fera le heat se meurt de
l'été 2010 9 tintin
un magnifique magnifique samani on peut
arrêter sur jean bouin
jour 3 est celui qui ne va pas parce que
c'est le jour 3 lui qu'il va la loisne
les grands esprits ce pour quoi bon les
gars troisième jour il va falloir écrire
les petites paroles posé sur le son
j'entends par là la lide les harmonies
les bacs des ambiances et faire le prix
mix pour envoyer tout ça à l'ingestion
qui va rendre le morceau écoutable ça
donne envie de dire non
j'aimerais savoir de quoi vont parler
vos paroles à vous nous ça va être
latinos séduction du voile à nous on va
sur employés de l'espagnol d'accord on a
vu que dans les sons de ce type il ya
beaucoup de mots en espagnol telles que
trafic était pas mal l'idée c'est de
changer un peu ce truc là et d'amuser
quoi ce qui me rend triste et c'est
moment émotion dans cette vidéo je sais
ce que tu veux dire je vous apprécie
blues jazz et qu'au final on se voit pas
tant que ça parce qu'on est chacun donc
j'aimerais faire un petit quart
nakasone encore à l'essai moment lol
séverine loeb les gars donner tout
derniers jours allez-y à fond les gars
allaient ramener cette coupe à la maison
qui ramènera la turbie
gaccio bisons et c'est partie technique
de putelat d'espionnage ça marchera plus
vraiment moment je dis ça sans voix
quand même ton fan fin il est fissurée
dégagé maintenant allez on s'en va aller
pourquoi j'ai gadonneix to grow là vous
donner tous les mecs
donc je pense qu'il faut écrire ces deux
mecs qui sont in love d'une meuf pas la
même offre
c'est quand même et ils en font des
caisses et des caisses genre s'il ya des
problèmes sur la ligne 6 je viendrai te
chercher en voiture au travail personne
personne ne vais pas citer sous la
douche et toilettes propres
je suis là je serai ta serviette il faut
pas tomber dans la parodie il faut qu'on
se dise des mecs qui font un hit de
l'été il aurait vraiment dit dans leur
son premier doublé effets spéciaux
j'ai même pas qu'elle ait pression à
maxima je sais pas puisque c'est pas
nous qui allons mettre ton vous devez
retirer leurs pierres moi je veux des
billets de d'argent chocolat et regarde
bien ça va créer une tour eiffel
c'est le troisième et dernier jour le
plus important c'est la phase d'écriture
et d'enregistrement
avant de livrer le tout aux mixes freddy
astarté dans la nuit et il a beaucoup
plus avancé que moi vu que moi j'ai fais
vraiment zéro parole 1 par contre il ya
quelqu'un qui je pense que vous êtes
dans l'équipe de squeeze du ricae vous
voulez pas que l'on fasse des sons parce
que vous débranchez tout à chaque fois
c'était mon petit coup de gueule je me
permets et on dit pas grand chose on est
très sympa que l'équipe technique mais
là j'ai l'impression qu'il ya un petit
truc devenir aller ça allait clairement
je pense qu'elle même corruption
sortez tout ce qui a donc empoché sa les
déballer tout déballer tout jamais un
paul gérémie mec t'es tu t'es mis un peu
le trou beaucoup trop vite dit rémi
grave du tout va s'il te plaît t'as même
pas le temps de te dit jérémy il était
déjà venu bazire ont commencé à écrire
on va écrire pour toi le début le
premier truc c'est les
contractualisations genre ouais ouais
faut la relation 1-2-3 ok faut trois
syllabes chaque moment avec toi genre
tout se passe avec à quoi il peut rien
faire sans vie sans toi je suis une
merde dans l'armée mais qu on commence
juste avec à chaque fois que je te vois
tu vois là et raymond s'intensifier tout
ce qu'on accroche soutenir un truc genre
nos regards se croisent c'est comme si
genre s'était pas encore sa meuf tu vois
nous regardent croisés je me noie nos
regards se croisent et je me
ça passe j'ai testé à chaque fois se
voit au regard non on va écrire ce à une
vitesse dans une heure c'est bouclé
sache le là on aurait vraiment en mode
bat les couilles pas à chaque fois que
je te vois ça commence comme ça qu'est
ce qui peut se passer après un deuil
contacter suisse des sourires mais tu
craques sur le sourire moi de sourire ou
rire mais soupire face au mec que tu
embrasses koudou jeannette driss a avoué
qu'elle y vive polémique que du liffe
sa semoule à verser dans le dos bon à 20
mais ces loyers des z'allumés faire
plaisir à mon vin payés je suis aussi
beaucoup il peut juste sortir roselyne
gueule et ça faire plaisir mon papy fait
rire mais faut voir à quel point on a
envie que ce soit un peu crédible ou
d'un coup on tombe sur un truc sur l'abm
arrangeur savane tu vas t en tout cas
c'est le cas précisant que j'avais en
tête dans le thème voilà quand même que
j'ai inventé c'était ça à chaque fois
que je te vois nos regards se croisent
et je me noie ça marche
ton sourire sourire souris infinie on
avance bien le truc
ouais qu'on aime bien tu as joué
l'invitent à dîner dans sa tête c'est un
peu genre te globe on n'est pas des mecs
race il fait l'amour chao genre de
pierre sémard à saint-louis de pierre
que du granit genre de granit
ça serait un bon plat ou un groupe de
rock granit ton sourire je vais te dire
je rêve que nos lèvres entre en contact
non donc là en fait il te reste le truc
du début c'est sa chance à saitama
trouvé ça j'ai pas trouvé ensemble tout
le reste moi je pour l'instant j'ai rien
qui me qui m'irrite ok bah je pense
qu'on va juste peaufiné par go way un
bisou et au pire et le sourire on
l'enlève
il ya d'autres choses ainsi un peu joué
sur du coup un trait de caractère est
pas forcément un truc physique ta
douceur ta douceur ma douleur quand je
m'approche de toi je perds tous mes
moyens je rentre comme ça j'aurais été
vraiment les mecs c'est manger ouais
voilà ça c'est bien je te jure mais le
mois il vient de taper en 5 secondes et
je vous la fais en direct ça c'était dur
et là justement quand approche en
quelques mois ce qu ont rebondi là
dessus et qu'on perçoit qu est ce que ça
lui fait quand il a alors je pense place
et je vais tout donner
rien que pour ton nom je vais te donner
c'est ma beauté ah ouais ouais bon
cliché w mexes et pas squeeze et jakarta
qui faisait ce qu'on sait c'est qu'il
sait des latinos tu vois qu'ils sont
charmés repas comme l'outil sap dans ses
prochains elle encourt huit mecs je te
jeu j'avais des choses incroyables j'en
revends débat séduire c'est pas genre
mais c'est comme ça qu'on sur le dance
laury dance le mec s'approche d'une
natte et il l'a fait tourner commenté
et bien sachez qu'en colombie ont fait
tourner les meufs et samarie et nous en
france on fait tourner les serviettes et
c'est pas la même chose ça ne marche pas
du tout mais faut qu'on avance au ouais
je réfléchis et attend cher comme lucas
les amis ouais mec t'es squeeze la dame
a eu 12 millions de familles ont chanté
un taux très bravo pour tout le travail
que tu as fait et que tu fais mais juste
que tu as fait comme si tu avais une fin
de carrière
on a fini la phase d'écriture on a été
très rapide on s'attelle désormais à la
tâche qui est l'enregistrement ou freddy
est prêt il a le texte sur le téléphone
je sens à son pouls qu'il est très
angoissée de poser face à deux cadreurs
ainsi qu'un danger son j'ai sorti mon
best auto dessus d'ailleurs tu peux
faire un test ici tout de suite vas-y ça
va trouver ça veut dire petit langage
technique drop et veut dire qu'on
n'enregistre pas tout d'un coup mais on
fait soit mot par mot soit phrase par
phrase je pense qu'on est prêt à y aller
finalement tu l as dit ok bon toi moi
alors quand tu me poses tu dérailles on
peut soit way essaye de l'adoucir des
genres fait la plus mauvaise voie mais
envoie le dessus ok je vais tenter les
york un cône marbella
toi moi soleil ma belle à pasqua a sous
sa cellule à 300 l'agressivité que tu en
voilà
c'est vraiment garou le garou mais deux
c'est mieux
ok c'est officiel on a les mes paroles
les parallèles et pas
[Musique]
jordan à chaque fois que je te vois nos
regards se croisent et je me noie ta
douceur ma douleur quand approche un
autre gars que moi elle n'est pas encore
tiennent donc c'est dur petit côté
jalousie je vais tout donner
tu es ma beauté on va s'évader tu m'a
hypnotisé et ça va le faire
je cale la faire l'étau se resserre et
évidemment par extension je sens la
chaleur monte ça a du sens un goûter
c'est à toi j'ai attendu si longtemps
ce soir c'est notre moment c'est juste
toi et moi babe mais je te dit bye bye
si tu fais du salon attention donc on
est très intéressé par la personne en
face de nous mais si elle fait du salon
c'est bye bye le curseur de ça vous
mettez vous voulez mais nous on n'en
veut pas voilà refrain on va garder un
fait ce qu'il a fait en impôts je rêve
de toi je pense à toi et mon coeur fait
au parce que le choeur chante mais je te
dit bye bye
si tu fais du sale et oui mon rappel
voilà importante le relais c'est
maintenant le tour de mon couple est à
moi je perds le contrôle
quant au corps se frôlent quand tu
bouges en rythme quand tu me donne envie
ses toiles à rennes je vais pas hésiter
je peux pas résister
je peux pas éviter ils tournent tous
autour de toi mais c'est moi que tu veux
cette soirée on sait qu'on va la finir à
2 ils veulent tous de faire danser mais
tu t'en moques 2 faut vraiment arrêter
de faire semblant faut qu'on passe aux
aveux qu'on dise la vérité
voilà qu'on se dise un petit peu les
choses n'avancent pas mais il faut faire
le pas une petite team ne reggaeton
intervient dans la musique et elle fait
la chose suivante 4,4 tous les paroles
tout cas ce que je dois faire des dons
par an j'aime quand tu suis la vague
girl laval girl lavagne quoi et qui
était venue y compris la vague non voilà
c'est assez compréhensible pour tout le
monde puis là c'est le dernier aux
freins et on est bon départ et il l'a
rangé dans sa poche puis nous l'ont fait
ça pour chanter maintenant ça va la
fatigue est présente beaucoup je pense
qu'on va pouvoir faire un emploi sûr
fait des doigts sur moi de même sinon on
se met toujours en berne et garance là
bas qui est très fatigué également et
jérémy qui lui est très serein en tout
cas la non l'enregistrement se passe
plutôt bien il nous reste quatre mesures
a enregistré et après on aura fini ça
sera que du détail
je pense que le résultat final pour
devrait être hyper cool et donc voilà
c'est si vide comme comme discours ces
moments on pose ces moments il faut être
juste dans les temps mais il faut garder
le top line en tête je fais l'ingé son
pendant que lui procès reprendra et moi
je suis là je passe un bon moment aussi
et allez tu qu'on sentait tu donnes mais
je suis chaud là à rigaud à chaque fois
que je te vois nos regards se croisent
et je me noie ok il ya juste une fausse
note sur le je me noie le regard se
croisaient je me noie ya une note noah
et m'a pas de moi ça à chaque fois que
je te vois regards se croisent et je me
noie où elle est belle cela allait bien
ouais ouais devant elle est pas mal
elle me vint aussi - willy for the next
ok je vais tout donner
tu es ma beauté on va s'évader tu m'a
hypnotisé et ça va le faire jusqu'à la
faire l'étau se resserre joue sans la
chaleur monte est ok sympa je fais leur
faim
[Musique]
tant mieux ça va un peu mieux on a
croisé lui car il était ouais c'est vrai
que ça me rassure que d'autres côté ça
n'est pas bien non plus parce que lucas
disait que jordan va savoir pourquoi à
douter apparemment il clôturait sa
chaîne youtube est entendu qu'il voulait
arrêter la musique tout est que il
voulait renier ses parents c'est too
much mais bon moi faut dire que c'est
bien est ce un hit de l'été est
forcément pour créer un hit de l'été à
mon avis via le moment fatigue mais
surtout il faut que ça casse les
couilles nan parce que regarder un hit
de l'été il ya forcément un moment où tu
en as marre des spas sitôt après une
semaine plus personne n'est mais ce sont
ces fous
regardez-moi ça il nous reste un peu de
choses il nous reste que ce trou un peu
moyen là à combler après il ne restera
que quelques finitions à faire mais ça
c'est pas très loin pour voir avec
plaisir et couches que propose d'y aller
et de ne pas perdre plus de temps car il
est déjà 18h30
on y est depuis 14 heures j'ai trichot
prédit veut mourir tout le monde ici
veut mourir mais avec le sourire et
c'est le plus important
finition ce hit de l'été et je pense
qu'on va gagner incarnant un césar non
c'est pas pour les chansons ben tout
aller c'est à toi et là comme dans les
films un peu beauf avec des anges et
[Musique]
réalité on va y arriver et messieurs
dames les 18h38 nous avons une
demi-heure pour réussir allez c'est
parti m la daronne en a pris je donnerai
tout pour ma famille ok écoutons ça va
dire il ya plus d'énergie que tout à
l'heure j'ai trouvé ça pas trop
dégueulasse est allé bouffer mais on va
y aller
allez go go go
m la daronne un abri s'éloigner des
ennemis pas du tout c'est pas du tout ma
phrase en plus - les amis messieurs
dames il est temps pour moi de poser sur
la suite du refrain aller plus penser
mais je te le dit bye bye bye bye
bye bye c'est une fée du sage de me dit
bye bye
bye bye si tu fais du sort allait bien
quand même tout paraît si on a refait
une toujours 2 toujours quoi eux
ouais toujours quoi 3 non allez on y va
je perds le contrôle quant au corps se
frôlent quand tu bouges henry quand tu
me donnes envie je vais pas hésiter je
veux parler du cégep att
j'ai mal indique l'esa casse les
couilles hockey puisque c'est comme ça
alors à les freiner mais la daronne à
l'abri je donne tout pour aller vous
qu'il se moquait ok c'est bon c'est bon
mec sociale tu deviens milliardaire mec
c'est vrai ouais ok résume chaud
m la daronne habré je donnerai tout pour
ma famille je lui ai dit tu es
milliardaire samedi midi avec tin les
mecs à darron à l'abri je donnerai tout
pour ma famille ouah on al aoula
ça va franchement on a fait moins
combien 20 prises pour salah tellement
beaucoup mon gars en joie la joie non
sauvegarder directement hop on va aller
voir lucas on a fini
[Musique]
ce chemin qu'on a fait dix fois plus que
grave je vais refaire mama roulades mais
genre avec énormément de fatigue
regardez bien la roulade fatigué c'est
dix fois revient à c'est vrai que c'est
très moche c'est fou cette porte à
chaque fois je n'oublie regardez bien
dans l'état dans lequel on va les
retrouver
ouais
[Musique]
regardez la tête des dogues sont avec
nous elle a le sourire
l algérien hilal suis au sourire parce
qu'ils ne vont plus entendre sens auto
tune on n'a pas encore bouclé on va être
là jusqu'à 21h je sens vous avez
vraiment des petits yeux voilà ça y est
la saison n'a pas d'être ça du tout mais
que c'est ça je te mets dans une pièce
j'ai fait écouter des spas sitôt
non-stop 3,82 saison des messages
actuels cherchant manie qu'ont appris le
même exemple c'est à dire en fait
d'espacité aux comptes illégaux la
première fois tu dis ouais lourd
en fait on a tellement marre de
l'entendre au bout d'une semaine que là
nous en fait avec nôtre son ca fait le
même effet merci pour ces trois jours
les gars à dans une semaine je fais un
petit câlin même si pour les gens il va
se passer une seconde pour nous il va se
passer une semaine à nous je vois et
sacem bisous
[Musique]
nous sommes à la fin doit animer la
vidéo j'ai même que la force
y a plus qu'une seule caméra y'a plus
l'équipe technique parce qu'en fait on
avait tourné une outro tout à l'heure
pour les trois jours mais en fait on
décide de faire faire parce que on
trouve que c'est marrant que ça se
termine maintenant en fait ce délire de
trois jours non-stop à travailler à
faire le mérite de l'été possible c'est
cool ça se termine à la fin du troisième
jour et que chacun découvre ce que
l'autre a fait à la fin du troisième
jour alors on n'a pas encore fait mixé
et masterisé tout nickel comme il faut
les sont évidemment bien génération à
qui on envoie toutes les pistes
extérieures et qui gère tout ce qui est
des sybelles effet sur la prod effet sur
la voie
l'auto tune y régler note une paru utile
et des photos on est d'accord avec ça
exactement c'est pour simplifier vous
prenez un plat de cuisine tous les
ingrédients ont des mélanges pour que
c'est un goût excellent donc on n'a pas
fait ça enfin on l'a fait faire par un
algorithme un site ce qui est un
algorithme extra donc ça c'est qu'outre
a largement fait ce sera pas parfait va
pas nous pas par le site mais du coup
c'est exactement la même chose donc je
suis à la fois heureux et à la fois je
suis triste parce que s'assigne la faim
de trois jours de ouf tu as a way
c'était cette époque on écoute on est
fâché fomichev oublie moi je suis
d'accord et celui qui gagne il écoute
les leçons de l'autre sur l'autre en
premier match fou mais c'est bien qu'ils
s'affrontent les capitaines d'équipé
vous d'oeil à les égos 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 3
du coup le votre boulot oui je suis très
excité mais comme on le sait que
s'appelle bye bye bye ok j'ai la
pression à chaque fois
tu te vois tous regards se croisent et
je me noie ta douceur ta douleur quand
tu raccroches un autre gâteau ça va le
faire jusqu'à la faire les tous au sel
je sens la chaleur pour tes frères
adam tous ces longs
de soi c'est notre moment c'est juste
toi et
abbey mais je te dit bye-bye si tu fais
du sal
[Musique]
je rêve de toi je penses quoi toi et mon
café
[Musique]
fatima est bas
bye bye
bye bye c'est une fêté ça
je perds le conforte dans nos par ses
formes quand tu bouges sans rythme quand
tu me donne envie
ils sont tous autour de toi mais c'est
moi tu veux cette fois laissé covan
ira pas
je rêve que toi et je te dis pas et bas
bye bye
bye bye situe fêter ça
on
les violons les gars ça va être chaud
alors à l'unfcu au gabon félicitations
c'est très très lourd ça me rendais pas
compte de trois jours la puissance de ce
bravo les gars c'est pas la fatigue qui
parle c'est vraiment très lourd merci je
vais vous botte très transparent goût
talent on a écouté notre son on l'a
vraiment très cool quand c'est dit vas-y
où aller fumer
la section plus ilsont lme longue tu
vois même pour la mise ap
nous sommes dix fois plus dégueulasse je
vous préviens ça sonne très d'écouter la
vôtre moment là bas moi je suis beaucoup
beaucoup
bah ouais j'ai un devis de pression
c'est de çà vient pas la pression mais
j'ai la classe comme année
[Musique]
rabbani un routeur dîner l'eau gelée
juste évitée a dit elle dans sa tête
elle veut déjà se marier que lui mais
que du muscle du défunt khalife que la
médina mary bybowl pas leur classement
[Musique]
m
mr
le changement de décor
mais le stress est de 2,6 soit clair
pour trois jours de taf c'est monstrueux
c'est monstrueux tout cas bon bah les
amis nous allons nous faire changer par
une seule chanson française messieurs à
dans une semaine
et bravo c'est incroyable je suis le
replay direct bouger tant la cam jury
fédéral je suis proche de celle envoyée
le je le mets dans la veine purement un
voiture ouvert la fenêtre
félicitations bravo les voyait tous à
dans une semaine ou plus
[Musique]
bien bonjour et salue sa ferme du roy
sports genigraph du temps à redescendre
ça fait une semaine n'a pas vu une
semaine qu'on a fini les sons on a reçu
la version mixée prête à être jugée par
la grande artiste de français qui va
venir s'asseoir ici dans quelques
instants les gens croient que les
blagues jusqu'à maintenant
vous croyez que quelqu'un déguisé genre
une blague ou alors oui si je vous dis
que cette personne a fait plus que
j'écoutais déjà ses musiques
il y a dix ans est bon car son mélange
jus disant ok base et continue et il a
sorti un album il ya pas si longtemps
elle à la reddition vient de sortir on
va leur dire quand il sera là toujours
pas toujours pas voilé la trêve de
suspense et l'énergie vous croyez tout
ce qu'une blague
ok je devrais j'avais prédit l'avenir
et vous allez-vous mettre applaudir
cette vision mais cela
ok merci aux lyonnais devenu c'est trop
trop cool c'est un honneur que tu sois
là
il ya comme un malaise là on a tous un
max de pression c'est normal ça y est
vous faire sans vous il va pas vous
mangez higgins a jugé la phrase là c'est
terrible
merci d'être venus merci peut-être
libéré sa sortie l'arrestation de ton
album yes ceinture et surtout tu remplir
un stade de france bientôt tu vas faire
un stade de france de france en
septembre le 28 septembre
je paie vos plats italiens qui est
autant la jag vite et tu nous invites ça
fait plaisir mais ça vous entendu parler
son bon je te recontextualise le truc
le concept de la vidéo c'est que on a
fait deux équipes kesa et freddy et moi
et joey cas et on a chacun de notre côté
fait ce qu'on pense être un hit de l'été
en trois jours c'est peu en retrait mais
on peut pas faire plus tout à fait
décent enfin je n'ai jamais fait ça peut
le faire s'étonne que son temps question
d'un spears va il veut sentir le truc
faut le vivre
donc on va voir ça tout de suite très
bien j'ai vraiment hâte d'écouter ce que
ok alors ils ont fait un son en
s'inspirant de quel univers plutôt du
côté de va bene la jeune ok ok nous on a
pris un délire plus latino genre gipa
lien mode à venir
tu vois ce genre de procédés sont très
différents leur son appel mirador le
nôtre s'appelle bye bye lequel tu veux
mais renault c'est pour mon 50 ans c'est
déjà une petite victoire
on va écouter ça tous ensemble puis on
va écouter l'autre et puis on se
retrouve pour le débris la légende
question c'est parti avec vlc player
c'est pas ces partis faire mal à le
première classe pour jeu
où l'on testé
mais à
[Musique]
on veut pas encore ton avis sur le saut
mais je pense qu au premier abord il a
bougé la tête pour moi ça me suffit ah
ouais après il est juste polis comme ça
j'aime les comme ça longtemps du prince
tu t'attendais pierre s'est agréablement
sont plus forts c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour l'équipe freddy pour l'équipe ok on
passe à notre sang nous c'est les jordan
qui a fait toute la preuve et nous on
est ado dessus on me coupait ses
bâtiments
n'est-il pas ça n'a rien à voir tlj
désamorce déjà à l'amorçage à la bougie
la tête comme ça j'en suis vraiment un
bâtard c'est parti
je rêve de toi jour dans ce cas toi j'te
dis pas et bas
bye bye
si tu fais du sage petit pays bas
heim
bye bye si tu fais du ca
oh les gars j'ai une pression s'é tait
c'est terrible franchement honnêtement à
welch précécent games in à 8,0 brief les
premiers couplets près refrain carrément
refrain on tend à faire des connaisseurs
c'est vrai en sus des vrais pros
jugement que je vais apporter votre
pointure parce que vous avez vraiment
chanter il ya un effort c'est un son dd
sa part demeure sa part de l'homme hrc
est vraiment dans un vrai contexte je
pense que vous avez vraiment ravi vous
n'êtes pas c'est dur de vous départager
j'ai apprécié de titres sur les portes
tu venais avec moi sur mon disque plus
en plus en dépensant ok là jusqu'à ce la
discussion est vraiment car une équipe
tu veux une deuxième écoute voûté ok
c'est bon t'as tout en tête pense que
j'ai tout attendait ça ne voudra pas
dire regardez la fait pas à ripley sur
le regard de guînes je peux marquer des
points de tête
n'oubliez pas le stade de france 2 game
et le stream allez c'est quoi ça
monsieur petit col avec heaven paris
rien ne me fera peur on achète sa
romance bien sûr moi j'en ai quatre chez
moi alors ayrton les points forts de
chaque sont les malentendus de miradors
de refrain il est très efficace
je suis entièrement d'accord de l'autre
côté on est surpris par ce concept on
pas chanter d'oser comme ça sur le son
ça ramène son truc genre de match quand
on veut écouter son plein
c'est vrai c'est vrai plus dur avec eux
et je pense je suis producteur radio
ben je sois programmateurs radio que
j'écoute les deux sont je pense à mes
auditeurs et
j'opterais pour bien sûr contestation de
son pouvoir m honnêtement je suis assez
d'accord est un vrai délire était de
vérité le vôtre il est prêt medellin
colombie un petit peu ma chanson qui se
prête le tête un peu moins aux français
et en france on a plus l'habitude de ces
styles de reggaeton qui est assez
d'hommes et silverlight à paris et
maintenant on écoute action l'ellipse et
on le juge nous remercieront pas tenir
plus longtemps
c'est vrai que c'est un honneur c'est
trop cool car un artiste de ton calibre
viennent ici plein de temps d'ailleurs
au studio pourra juger des sons de nous
quoi je suis honoré de ça je dis rien
c'est mille fois et puis ne sais pas a
bien sûr fait chaud la réédition de
l'album de green et à venir au stade de
france on y sera peut-être qu'on se
croisera verdict une ou des âmes est
passé non je veux pas merci grâce à ibm
j'allais faire du bien mais tu chantes
maintenant aux qui change de mains ok
quand même dans le public
trop content et merci ging c est bon
c'est la bonne chose pour la suite et
continue de tonique et l'ours en terres
en somme ça y est bien joué c'est ben
amos a justement vu qu'il avait du coin
de l'oeil mais quand j'ai vu qu'il
faisait des trucs comme chez des voisins
c'est bon ouais ouais c'est cool sur
notre sont la grave bouger je regarde un
peu changé d'ailleurs m envoyant m
j'avais envie de faire ça avec ses
manques pas comme ça le cfc ou fois en
néon la vie mais je suis choqué
j'écoutais il ya dix ans avec la sexion
d'assaut wati by night se sentait trop
les soies watson bien là
c'est quoi oh on n'a qu'à lui dire bye
bye bye bye bye bye si tu vécu ça bon un
coin bravo territoire et je suis au cap
ou bep ce qu'a dit games ça peut passer
à la radio de demain
un mec qu'a pas vu notre vidéo ils y
croient vraiment quoi dire c'est quoi ce
nouveau gars crédit gladius correspond
pas du tout mais un truc samatiguila
t-il
j'appris trois choses la première game
si les méga gentil après la deuxième mon
couple est nul à chier
[Rires]
je ne sais plus je n'en reviens un
switch moi il m'a complimenté du medec
nous avons c'est parce qu'on est sur ma
chaine hifi
bref s'il faut retenir c'est que ton nom
est que vous avez gagné à ses yeux
mais aux yeux des gens et oui vous
n'êtes pas aller vite alors il ya un
moyen très simple de départager pour que
les gens votent c'est extrêmement sain
nous allons aller messieurs tournée nous
de cliff pendant deux jours alors tu
gabarret ok je vous emmène au portugal
alors pourquoi au portugal parce qu'en
fait en france
la météo allait arracher un style
extérieur on doit faire des clips de
l'été l'équipe de l'été ces genres
suntree ciblage de la danse enfin tout
ça gros bisous pas tous nos amis
portugais qui donc on vous adore en vous
efforçant j'ai de la famille là-bas
nous allons ensuite sortir dans les
prochains jours probablement 48 heures
nos deux clips sur ma chaîne youtube
les deux en même temps à la même heure
le clip qui fera le plus de vues on va
dire
quatorze jours c'est ce qu'il faut pour
voir ses seins sont des cols ou pas au
cube qui fera le plus de vues gagnera le
vote des gens pourquoi je suis celui qui
fera le plus de vues ça veut dire qu'il
sera celui qui aura le plus c'était
replay est donc ce sera la musique aura
le plus plu aux gens si vous avez aimé
l'un des deux sont pas déjà assez cool
vous pourrez l'écouter puisqu'il sera en
version entière avec le clip eto'o sur
youtube et ensuite bas mot le replay de
manière à faire gagner l'équipe qui
selon vous a fait
et le gars ne savaient quoi vous savez
quoi je vais déjà des cadeaux et avoir
le vote de gibbs et les tout petits
c'est fou ça laissait numéro je m'amuse
et alors je sais pas si je pourrais
aller au bout de son délire mais ça me
ferait chialer de rire plein de 200
finissent vraiment radio et y ait des
gens qui se disent ça il est bien ce
nouveau sion c'est qui ce nouvel artiste
alors si sa vie est ici sauf celui ticad
radiologue 14 jours je vous promets pas
que je vais réussir puisque c'est un
gain que je maîtrise 0 mais je vais tout
donner pour qu'il passe en radio
je sais pas dans quelle station je sais
pas quand je n'ai pas sur une web radio
à quoi joue bien c'est cool en
conclusion pas parler j'en suis senti
assez émouvant et ses montées par te
baigner dans le montage sera etc sinon
y'a pas de quoi pour être franc avec
vous quand tu m'as envoyé de mix du coup
ils votent sont là il ya 48 heures je
les écoutais non-stop en voiture et
c'est au soleil sous la douche et mettez
votre ordinateur sous la douche
mais d'un coup l'aï vraiment donc
c'était une magnifique aventure propose
un câlin général
allez en voir définitivement suis très
heureux de cas et à bientôt pour les
clips au même temps je pense à temps et
mon café y avait qu à sortir amaigrie
sans intermédiaire
bye bye bye bye
m
[Applaudissements]